so why don't we do a story with jen here
jen let's pick a story that maybe you
can uh uh give us some opinions on as
well all right
let me see here okay how about shaq's
message to his kids is that a fair one
to do is that what we want to do let's
do that one okay let's do that because
we we've talked about this so it's this
is a good one for us okay page three
our friend shaq who till today i'm
blocked because of the interview i did
with kobe you're still blind
message he says what a stupid question
to ask kobe what do you mean if i had
kobe's work ethic who would i have been
that's the dumbest question i've ever
heard bam and he blocked me anyways all
right so let's go through shaq's message
to his kids
i'm rich we're not rich 17 kill news
former lsu tiger and basketball legend
shaquille o'neal delivered it's so weird
the introduction why would you say
former lsu tiger why wouldn't it be the
former laker nba hall of famer but
former lsu tiger and basketball agent
shaquille o'neal delivered some harsh
news to his six children he told them
we're not rich i'm rich on a recent
podcast shaq says they're kind of upset
with me not really upset but they don't
understand the retire hall of fame hoop
star says he wants his children to make
his own make their own way in the world
o'neil's net worth hovers around 400
million dollars but he has made it very
clear to his children he expects them to
all go to college and if they have an
idea that they want to invest in they
will have to pitch it to him just like
anyone else babe what do you think about
this story i think uh i think this
sounds good it's very familiar we go
much better right there oh thank you um
i think it sounds very familiar because
do you hear it do you hear it or no i
don't hear it i don't i don't hear it no
let's give her your mic here just do
this baby okay
go for it okay
okay
okay musical mics um
sounds familiar sounds very familiar yes
because we we
basically
talk about the same kind of principles
with our children
you know whenever they're wanting
anything we talk about
being able to earn that even small
things you know if they want to buy
something they're like well hey can i go
get the money from my
piggy bank those piggy banks that you
put together for them chico was like
where's the key to this mom because i
want to buy you know this video game or
whatever it might be i was like i don't
know where the key is ask your dad so
it's about the saving principles i
intentionally lost the key okay so
hopefully we're going to lose the key
for like 10 years for the safe just
kidding
but it's in a place that i don't even
know but i think they understand that
they don't have the money because like
you know if there's something they want
to buy you'll say look we'll go buy it
and and the kids will be like well i
don't have any money dad i don't have
any money so i think you know they
understand that this is the most curious
one would you agree dylan's the one that
says hey daddy how much is this house
i'm like dylan who cares he says no i
want to know because my friends are
asking they say you're rich how much is
this house i'm not telling you how much
is this house somebody told me this
house is a lot of money daddy yeah
they'll say like daddy are you a
millionaire yet and then you'll say
by the way i gotta tell you what what uh
dylan said dylan goes like this dylan
says hey daddy are you a millionaire yet
i see i you know i would say yes he says
but you're not a billionaire like batman
yeah he says that batman's already built
so
can you imagine that never be good
what's up with this right
joker yeah yeah we can never rise above
the opinion of our children
it is true it is true uh uh uh you know
uh senna sent us so funny senna's like
daddy i want a ferrari yeah
so that's great i said daddy who's gonna
buy it for you baby you're going to buy
it for me i'm not buying it for you yeah
you buy it for me i said no you're going
to buy it for yourself yeah but uh so
you agree with what shaq has to say yeah
absolutely and i know i've i've heard
the kids say other things like that like
cena says or dylan may say you know i
want a lamborghini and then you you'll
say like well who's gonna buy it for you
and he's like well i don't have any
money and he's like well you gotta you
gotta work to make the money yeah to be
able to buy that so do you remember that
one time we're driving the car t-con
villain are sitting in the back seat and
uh
uh uh so i say i'm papa's there all the
kids are there and i say hey tycho dylan
are we one day going to be in business
together like we all me you daddy all of
us are going to be in business together
take on dylan say they look at each
other very seriously they say um that
it's a very serious question let us
think about it
it's good remember that he's like yeah
let us think about it that's a lesson
out there so listen to everyone out
there you don't have an immediate answer
let us think about how to marinate first
and then and then 10 minutes later i'm
like wow these guys are wanting to think
so they're talking to each other in a
back seat in the escalator i'm like so
daddy we talked about it i said okay
what do you guys want to do we're going
to start a business together not with
you it's just going to be
i'm not going to daddy good for you so
they're trying to say we're going to
make our own money we don't need your
help tom what do you think about the
story with chad you know it's
interesting jen that story you know i
can kind of relate to that because i
have that same conversation with dash
because i'm asking him if i can borrow
some money from him actually and he'll
buy me some of the kids making money
right now but it is something that you
have to deal with for sure shaq's
interesting because remember he was
clearly motivated by the fact that his
dad didn't give a damn about him right
he had the song biological didn't bother
so he was raised by a step dad a very
strict military guy made him what he is
yep treats him as this but it's
interesting that he has that as his
background it reminds me of what daniel
craig said said recently when the bond
movie came out that he's had to leave
any money for his kids i just i find it
weird here's my question for shaq
you're the busiest guy in show business
there isn't a commercial you don't do
you run to atlanta do tnt all the time
you're you're a police officer here
you're a dj there how much time are you
spending with your kids because i've
never heard about any of your kids i'm
kind of surprised that none of them have
started to excel at something so i'm
saying basketball for
but i just you know when you're not
around your kids as much as shaq isn't
probably
and it's just such a throwaway line
saying you go make your own money you
give me a business plan if you want to
do something i i find it a little
callous that's just me personally i get
it yeah you know you want to make your
kids but that's not my style i gotta
tell you i take the opposite of prayer i
absolutely love this the fact that he's
coming out and saying
i'm rich you guys you ain't nothing you
haven't proved anything to the world
there's nothing worse and this is why i
respect you guys so much making your
kids work for and earn it and read and
shoot hoops and baskets there's nothing
way worse than entitlement and i've grew
up with a lot of rich kids in miami and
it's always the rich kids that don't
want to work for it that just kind of
feel like they're going to get the
inheritance that always end up resulting
into nothing and it's always the even
i'm not saying that all wealthy kids
won't turn out successful but it's the
ones that their parents implement some
work ethic and not the silver spoon
effect that always accept yeah but
you're you're making it seem like the
parents that just give their kids money
where they don't have to worry about it
it's the attention it's the focus it's
raising them the right i think tom's
talking about extremities like that's
the extremity of like oh you're just
gonna not you know help him you know
because that's the point like for
example my dad two times in his life was
what you would consider rich to us right
and so he uh there was twice and when
the first time was when i was a kid he
owned a dealership he owned a restaurant
he owned four businesses by the way he
had no papers he was 28 years old and
had no papers and he owned four
businesses and i
i i didn't know he had i was working
with the mechanic like at the he had a
dealership so when the cars would come
in i would have the mechanic i would
move the cars i would watch the cars so
my dad had money but i had no idea the
second time i was 12 i was like 12 years
old he got into real estate when the
real estate was booming and he was he
had 12 houses i was working with the
guys in the crew i was putting up the
stucco like my dad had money i just
didn't know i didn't know until i became
an adult that there was twice because in
the market crash and he lost everything
and lost everything again twice um but
he instilled that and never did he say
well he would tell me one day this is
all going to be yours but it's like but
for now get your ass to work because i
mean like that's that's the language one
because he didn't want to instill like
i'm building this for you but you're
gonna you're gonna earn it you know so
that was a lot of conversation about
that like one day it's all gonna be
yours but then meanwhile pick up that
plywood now pick up that sheetrock pick
up that hammer so i worked in the cruise
after school and he would pay me uh he
would give me 50 a day
a 250 a week and i would have to buy my
own stuff you know like that's you know
but one day it's gonna be yours but
you're gonna learn the value so that's
you know there's there's just two sides
of it my dad wasn't like shocked like
you're not gonna have it but also he
wasn't like here you go no you're you
know you're going to learn the value of
a dog
what do you think about this uh you know
i i think it's i think it's fun rhetoric
but i mean if i follow shaq on on
instagram and and you know he's around
his kids a lot at least at least
whenever he's around is because the
camera's on anyway who knows i don't
know it seems like they like they love
them
like they enjoy this relationship yeah i
think that he is trying to look he was
born in newark he would you know he was
raised you know not he wasn't raised
crazy poor but but
you know he he thinks he's got an
incredibly hard work ethic and that's
probably what he took umbrage with you
by the way thank you tanner's this is on
you guys you know there's three million
of you you should be peppering shaq on
twitter every day saying hashtag sit
down with pbd valuetainers this is what
are you doing guys this is apes together
strong moment here we need three million
of you just to pepper shack instagram
and twitter for the next two days tell
them to come sit down and piece it up
the next sit down after mafia states is
pbd it's jack all right so the look the
i think it's great to instill a work
ethic my father was the same way you
know you never you never got anything
you had to earn everything and it did
get as you got older and you understood
like it did become frustrating it became
frustrating like that all right he's
like well you know you gotta earn it i'm
like that well what's the deal like come
on what's the deal like can i have it or
not like what are we doing here so i
think
look i i'm not a parent i don't know how
it goes you got to be a teacher you have
to teach them you have to instill them
discipline is everything you you want
you know we talk about the path we've
talked about this extensively like how
do you
give you when you give your kids
everything you never had
they become everything that you never
were talk about we talk about that a lot
you know so it's like how do you your
success comes from your struggle but
your kids are never going to have that
struggle and you can't really emulate
that too much because then they'll grow
to resent you right so
i tell you i don't know i like what he
does his kids seem to love him i think
he walked out you know that's kind of
like every great coach every great
mentor every great boss every every
great friend you've ever had knows when
to push and knows when to pull right
good feedback there
ladies if you're folks if you're
watching this in about five minutes
we're going to do the next giveaway
which is going to be what a louis
vuitton uh scarf it's going to be the
tory burch sandals and it's going to be
the gucci
wallet which is like 1300 we'll do that
your next 20 super chat you'll be in the
raffle you got probably five more
minutes to get that twenty dollars into
being the next super chat here's what i
would tell you
a guy named art williams who is the
founder of ao williams used to be with a
company called larry uh uh wydell and
reed and then he left and it became
primerica city group bought it all this
stuff it's term insurance company
there's the just do it guys that's right
that's just this guy yeah williams so he
said when he was a coach and he was
working with coach bear bryant or he was
a coach himself he would tell us players
you better get your ass off the field if
you're injured don't even think about if
you're injured to lay down there get up
and get to the sidelines don't even walk
slowly to the sidelines i'm not gonna
come and get you you get your ass up and
get to the silence that's what he would
say he says but in a leadership
recording he said the following he said
but let's face it if i knew they
couldn't get up i'm going to go pick
them up and bring them to the sidelines
but you never tell them to believe that
because you want them to use as much of
their own sheer strength to stand up so
a big part of parenting could be listen
dude you got to figure this out thing
out for yourself you got to pull
yourself you know you got your little
red wagon to pull whatever you're the
michael's legacy the aguilar the center
legacy the ellsworth legacy but david
you know one day sosnick legacy you got
to go do your part but if [ __ ] hit the
fan you know who's the first person
that's going to go yeah you know it yeah
you know if something happens his son
needs something you know you're the
first person to go there so but the
tricky question is the following here's
a tricky question do you guys believe
you're going to leave inheritance to
your kids yes whatever whatever you have
are you going to leave a hundred percent
with your kids no no whatever you have
are you not at 100 apart absolutely not
where are you at uh you're adding they
don't need to wait for me to leave them
an inheritance for kim and i to leave
them inherited because we're giving them
vision purpose and education and i have
pointed out to them that says look you
got to go get your grades you need to
get your test scores so that you have
the maximum number of opportunities
whether that's college or whatever it is
in life you want the maximum
opportunities
you need to to work to get it and i and
i've sent bailey articles and student
loans yeah i said you are blessed
because you're not going to get out of
college with student loans so you won't
have that burden as you produce the
opportunity following your education and
so that i give them purpose i give them
vision and we teach them consequence if
you if you slack now you're going to
limit the number of opportunities you
have you work hard you can have the
maximum number of colleges you're going
to do a hundred percent you're going to
do 100 here's why
i don't know who else would be more
worthy than my kids i mean unless
there's some charitable cause or
something okay or something let me ask
you a question are you gonna do 100
well give your kids all your all your
every uber you know like frequent flyer
miles you have are you going to give all
your money 100 to your kids no i don't
think 100 what would you give them
certainly some inheritance but okay
people forget how long people live and
you're going to use a lot of your money
not everyone has 20 million dollars or
10 million dollars
when you die is your estate gonna say a
hundred percent of your money goes to
your kids or is it gonna go to some
charity i assume most people if they're
doing well they have a trust and they
have a trustee and i'm gonna have to go
to you guys
to you is it gonna go 100 to your family
wife and kids
a large portion
so then here's the other question
here's the other question let me give
you the other question i'll give my
answer as well here's the other question
the question this is the real question
you got four kids
you got two kids you got three kids
you got 10 million in your state 20
million in your state are you giving
every kid equally the same amount oh
that's a good question that ripped my
family apart man the ugly one has to get
the least
it was not not a significant amount of
money but my my mom is one of eight kids
and my grandmother my grandmother only
left uh six of them
uh money and left two people out left
two people out and there was property
that she only gave to three
and
i got to be honest and i love my
grandmother more than any human being
that's ever walked this face of the
earth i love that woman to death that
was a vindictive move but what was it
what was that
did she have one do you know her
reasoning she had reasons and then
afterwards it was the the the brothers
and the sisters got together and they
were like
you know look grandma had dimension at
the end she was angry
look let's just do the right thing and
and split this thing evenly and
some of the people were like no we're
gonna we're going with her last wishes
and they're like you're greedy it has
nothing to do with greed it's we're
honoring our mother's wishes and it
ripped the family in part rip until
today until today
they won't go to each other's funerals
like like
rip them apart they'll never speak to
each other similar to my family and i'm
telling you that we spent christmas
together we spent every holiday
interesting
no matter how far on long island about
how far south they got this was a tight
tight title horrible position to put
your mother in where she has to go ask
for something that she probably deserved
or if you're if you're going to keep
people out you got to tell them why i
think i mean there's got to be a reason
for it relationship broke down early
before i'm interested tom like you're
not afraid that you're your daughter and
your daughters love you to death you're
not afraid they're going to resent you
if you
you they know that what money you have
and that money is going to leave the
family and at least you could like leave
him in the will say here's everything
this is what i would do with it i would
say i'm giving a hundred percent okay so
i'll tell you
i'll tell you what we're doing
he says it's going to be a trust or a
foundation depending on the size and
there will be something for bailey
something for brooke and then they will
be trustees of the trust in the
foundation and we are going to already
be instilling in them in the things that
we support and the things that we do
they will already be unless i die in a
plane crash tomorrow afternoon right
they will already be instilled
we're already going to teach them what
we're doing and so when that's when it's
over they don't have to wait for the
reading of the world they'll say well
i've got something here i've got
something here i have no education debt
hopefully i've made something myself and
then we're both trustees to keep doing
what mom and dad were doing from the day
that we were old enough to understand
what they did with their money
i i i think so i had a story for one and
then we'll transition to the to the you
got two more minutes uh folks if you
want to get that tory burch sandals uh
what is it uh louis uh louis louis
scarborough and a gucci wallet we'll do
it on two minutes here so uh that's for
every woman valuetainer and every
persian valuetainer
by the way persian and michoacan
mexicans
one of the successful uh friends of the
family we had in iran was a lady named
shireen they had a son named ali who
ended up being a doctor and i don't know
what the sister's name was could have
been hirsa or something like that
anyways
so the way they did it is
they said it was so interesting my mom
told me the story they gave their wealth
while they were alive because they
didn't want their kids to be think
waiting for them to die so they get the
money
so they gave it well i think that's a
great idea yeah so they're like you know
what listen here's what we have here's
the money you're getting right now while
we're alive let's just enjoy we don't
want you to be like when his mom died
when is that then yeah so you know
that's one part but the other part also
like if you got a kid that ends up being
being a
bad habits drugs all this other stuff
you're going to give he's going to ruin
his life there was a book by jim stovall
called the ultimate gift yes it's a
great book it's a great book we've
probably given a few thousand copies of
this book away i think you gave that to
me like the first week we were dating as
well that's right i probably did the
ultimate gift yeah he gave you a book
first week of dating he gave me several
books yeah but the first week this is
the first book yeah the first 101
questions you asked before you get
engaged
wow that's the second date second date
had borders he came on strongly yes uh
he he knew what he wanted yeah second
date and then we had a meeting saturday
for how many hours uh like six maybe six
hours we went through every question not
a date a meeting i like to just have a
meeting
i love how you tell a girl you're gonna
give her the ultimate gift and you hand
her a book so my my lawyer showed up her
lawyers showed up it was very romantic
legal team was there we had a mediator
off to the side a court reporter by the
way jen
you know santa says you're going to give
me a corvette or a ferrari pink ferrari
you know when she does her little daddy
that you know if there's one kid that's
going to get it at senate i don't know
about that i don't think we would do
that to her no you don't know me too
well no no i think santa could pull it
i'm saying if there's one kid that can
pull it out of you let me let me explain
it to you though here's how i work the
way i work is very simple
we have in every possible way it's all
about incentives you hit it i want to do
more for you i don't want to do less for
you i'm all about more so if you wanted
xyz i want to do even more but i want
you to hit a certain earlier numbers
performance giving your best behavior
attitude all that stuff i want to be
able to do that so there's going to be
some kind of a
structure for the kids to be able to get
more than others they're all going to be
in a pretty decent situation but some of
them are going to get more the others uh
business-wise here's how i'm going to do
when the guys have an idea to run a
business my approach for business is
going to be the following way
you come you don't talk to me you talk
to him you don't talk to me with your
business ideas because i don't have that
kind of relationship with you if you
need me on a chair no problem if you
need me as an investor no problem you
have to convince him you have to
convince the lawyers not me so you talk
to them they hold you accountable to the
money they hold you accountable to what
you do those guys are getting a fee of
what the company does good so they're
not going to be like oh here you go 17
million dollars here you go it's a
million dollars here you go 300
in return i'm in the back i'm just
simply the one that's the chair but he's
holding you accountable the board is
holding accountable that's the way i'm
gonna approach it with these kids now
we're gonna find that in eight years if
it's right or wrong and then we'll talk
about on the podcast
i said we talked about it in 2020 2 100.
by the way
you know
this whole conversation started with sp
you know that he has something that he
calls the
shack tank
right like a shark tank yeah well he'll
have he'll have investors come in and
pitch him for 15 minutes
while he's got his you know board of
trustees or his conglomerate around him
and they pitch him with ideas so that's
probably what he's going to have his
kids do is come in and pitch the group
on their ideas he's not going to give
his kids stuff for free there's going to
be an incentive program we talked about
dwayne johnson being president one day i
would vote for shaquille o'neal as
president okay can you imagine shaq as a
president i would vote for shaquille
o'neal as president
press conferences would be great
yeah i was going to be the most dominant
vote yeah would he be the most dominant
yeah okay the first time i saw vladimir
putin he was in high school
i saw shaq play in high school right
before he went to lsu he played at the
u.s olympic festival he used to have
this in off olympic years he was on the
american team played at williams arena
mini minneapolis minnesota i went to the
game didn't know who he was there was a
half hour delay in the game because he
tore down the rim and he blocked 20
shots can you can you imagine shaq
against high school kids i saw it was
unbelievable by the way he lsu record i
think 14 or 15 blocks in a game i
remember that game when he did that he
was insane he's former lsu tiger
not laker
champion
we went
by the way we went to a lakers event
with uh do you remember that lakers even
with shaq and james worthy came over
said hello that whole we were playing
basketball on the stables
yeah it was really cool great experience
shaq's the speaker shaq comes in he gets
up so shaq you know your kids you know
the one of them looks like he's gonna
have a career what college gonna put him
into he says i'm gonna put him in lsu
they pay the best
[Laughter]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]